>> WHAT'S UP FELLOWS HOW ARE WE
DOING HOW ARE WE DOING THANK
YOU GUYS FOR JOINING THANK YOU
GUYS FOR TAPPING IN.
WE ASKED YOU IN THE APP AND ON
TWITTER. RYAN TALK TO US YOU
ARE THE MAN AT THE PEOPLE PUT
SOME OF THE TWEETS THAT YOU GOT
PULLED UP.
>> I'M NOT A MAN OF THE PEOPLE
I'M THE MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN TAKE
MY SPOT LIGHT THAT'S OKAY.
YOU DO A GOOD JOB.
>> YES.
>> I CAN'T PICK AND CHOOSE I
CAN'T JUST CHERRY PICK WHICH
COMMENTS I WANT TO READ HERE
THEY ARE ALL ON THE SCREEN WE
WILL GO THROUGH THEM HERE.
ALSO IN THE CHAT RIGHT NOW LET
US KNOW WHO YOU THINK WOULD
RIVAL THESE.
>> CAN WE START THERE?
LET'S START WITH 25 YARDS
RUSHING WHAT IS THAT?
-600?
LET'S -- I WANT TO START WITH
BAD VIBES BUT
>> BRING A LITTLE SOMETHING
MORE INTERESTING THAN THAT.
>> WE CAN'T EVEN DO 25+.
>> THE BETTER.
>> WHILE WE ARE STARTING OFF
WITH HOSTILITY GET TO KNOW.
TREVOR LAWRENCE OVER 12 1/2
RUSHING YARDS THIS I LOVE.
THIS I LIKE A LOT.
WE WILL REVISIT.
GREG WHICH WE CAN DO NO THINK
YOU SERVE.
JONES WITH THE TOUCHDOWN IN
OVER 100 YARDS RECEIVING.
>> THAT'S A LOT.
>> THAT'S A NO FROM ME.
>> MY EYE IS CRYING RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE I DON'T LIKE THAT.
>> I KNOW THERE'S SOME -- I
KNOW THEY ARE TOTALLY SET BUT I
WOULD ASSUME IT'S GOING TO BE A
LOT SO I CAN'T PICK HIM RIGHT
NOW IS SOME SPECULATION WOULD
BE JONES BUT I DON'T KNOW.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF I EVEN WANT
TO TAKE A GAS.
>> KNOW.
100%.
>> W MORRIS SAYS THE TOUCHDOWN
LOCK.
TERRIBLE WEATHER TONIGHT PICK
THE ENDER.
UNDER 39.
J WILLIAMS UNDER TOTAL POINTS.
MICHAEL OUT WITH 2+ TOUCHDOWNS.
ONE TOUCHDOWN IS +155.
IS THAT BARBERRY YOU HAVE ON?
>> HERE'S THE THING.
I'M REALLY BAD WITH KNOWING
WHERE I GET MY CLOTHES FROM.
AM I'M INSTAGRAM ADD GUY SO
I'LL SEE SOMETHING I'LL CLICK
ON IT AND JUST BUY IT.
>> WE NEED YOUR DAD IN THE
COMMONS TO TELL US.
>> YOU GUYS LET ME KNOW IF YOU
THINK RYAN WHERE HE GETS HIS
SHIRT.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW WELCOME TO
THE SHOW EVERYBODY WHO'S
TAPPING IN.
MY NAME IS GREG NEXT TO ME IS
THE MAN I LIKE TO CALL THE MAN,
THE MYTH, THE LEGEND HIS NAME
IS SAM RICHMOND NEXT TO ME IS A
MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
PRODUCER RYAN.
MAKE SURE YOU GUYS DROP YOUR
LIKES IN THE CHAT WE WILL
PICKING THAT AT THE END OF THE
SHOW RIGHT NOW WE NEED YOUR
HELP HOLDING THE SAME GAME
PARLAY FOR THURSDAY NIGHT
FOOTBALL.
TELL THE PEOPLE WHAT WE NEED.
>> I WILL REITERATE. WE NEED
HIM BACK.
I FEEL LIKE WE HAD TWO PLAYS
DROPPED I MIKE AND BY ONE OF
THE TWITTER COMMENTS THAT I
FEEL LIKE WE CAN DEBATE IF YOU
GUYS ARE COOL WITH IT.
TREVOR LAWRENCE LET'S GO TO HIS
RUSHING YARDS.
ARE YOU READY?
12+.
-160.
>> WE ARE NOT DOING TWO.
WE DRAW THE LINE IN THE SAND
RIGHT THERE.
>> OR WE CAN DO BOTH.
>> WHAT IS HIS ACTUAL LINE?
>> 12 1/2.
>> IT'S GETTING TOPPED OUT IN
REAL TIME.
WHILE YOU LOOK AT WHAT HIS
ACTUAL NUMBER IS I JUST WANT TO
SAY THIS IS STEVE WE ARE ON THE
SAME PAGE.
I THINK WE SHOULD NOT DO THIS
BRAD WHERE THE MONEY LINE IN
THIS PARLAY BECAUSE SPOILER BUT
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT VIEWS ON
THIS GAME OF WHO'S GOING TO
WIN.
FOR THE SAKE OF GOOD VIBES NO
MONEY LINE RIGHT HERE.
>> I LOVE THAT.
WE LOVE THAT.
I'M OVER HERE LAUGHING YOU GUYS
SEE ME LAUGHING BECAUSE I'M
LOOKING AT THE COMMENTS I LIKE
HOW BRIAN IS JUST NOT
ADDRESSING THEIR BARBERRY BUT
THE FURBEARING THEY ARE CALLING
HIS SHIRT IN THE COMMONS HE
JUST DIDN'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
IT.
>> THANK YOU.
OF COURSE I WILL READ THAT
COMMENT WHAT HE TALKING ABOUT?
AM TRYING TO MAKE MONEY HERE
GREG
>> IT'S LIKE 20 COMMON
>> WE ARE ALL TRYING TO MAKE
MONEY HERE TOO WE ARE ALL HERE
TO MAKE MONEY I DON'T KNOW EVER
SINCE YOU'VE BEEN TRYING TO GET
RICH WE HAVEN'T MADE ANY MONEY.
>> IF HE DOESN'T KNOW, IT'S NOT
BARBERRY.
>> ALL RIGHT LET'S GET TO THE
PACE THAT IS FUNNY THOUGH.
TREVOR LAWRENCE SHOULD WE LOOK
AT HIS RUSHING?
HE TALKED ABOUT IT.
>> I ROLL IT UP RIGHT NOW.
THE GAME BEFORE SEVEN THE GAME
BEFORE 32. 26-53 HE HASN'T GONE
OVER THAT NUMBER.
WHERE THE COMMENTATOR IS GOING
WITH THIS IT'S GOING TO BE VERY
WINDY.
VERY COLD AND IN MY EXPERT
OPINION THEY WILL TRY TO PLAY
IT ON THE GROUND.
>> SHOUT OUT TO DARREN HE
ATTACKED US ON THE COMMUNITY
POST EARLIER AND ASKED US ABOUT
NOTE TEAMS SCORING THREE
UNANSWERED AND I PROMISE WE
WILL HAVE A WEATHER REPORT.
LIKE HE SAID.
THIS DOESN'T LOOK LIKE FRIENDLY
FOOTBALL WEATHER.
>> IT DOES NOT.
>> I LOVE THE WEATHER REPORT.'S
I'M STEALING OUR GOOD BUDDY
MICHAEL'S JOB.
>> AS THE THEME OF THE PARLAY
WE SHOULD LEAN ON PASSING AND
UNDER.
RUSHING AND OVER.
>> YOU'RE OKAY WITH THAT
INCLUDING TREVOR LAWRENCE?
>> IT'S WHISKEY BUT SHOULD WE
PROMPT THE CHAT DO THUMBS UP
THUMBS DOWN ON THAT?
>> LET'S DO IT.
WHAT'S THE BET?
ARE WE LOOKING AT ZACH WILSON
OVER UNDER TREVOR LAWRENCE?
TREVOR LAWRENCE RUSHING YARDS
12+.
FOR THOSE -- IF THERE'S A BAD
BEAT FOR THEM THAT'S GOOD NEWS
FOR US.
>> WHAT'S THE LINE AT THE RYAN?
>> 12.5
>> WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN 12+?
>> WHAT ARE WE DOING GREG?
>> NOT 15+.
IT'S ONLY A THREE LACQUERS SO I
WANT 12 1/2.
TAKE IT.
>> R WEIKEL WITH THIS?
>> IF THE CHAT IS COOL WITH
THAT I'M COOL WITH IT.
WE GOT THUMBS UP.
LAWRENCE WILL GET SACKED ALL
DAY DON'T TAKE HIS RUSHING
YARDS.
JUST NOT GOOD VIBES.
LAWRENCE IS GOING UNDER IF YOU
GO TO 12 YOU MIGHT AS WELL GO
TO 15.
WE HAVE SOME RUSHING YARDS FROM
ZACH WILSON.
>> I DON'T NEED ANOTHER
QUARTERBACK RUSHING.
PASSING URINE SENDER.
>> WE DIDN'T EVEN ADD THIS.
>> ZACH WILSON UNDER 249-600.
>> THAT'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
ALRIGHT.
WE WANT TO DO THAT?
>> OR WE CAN DO 2 UNDER YOUR
UNDER RUSHING PROPS RIGHT NOW
YOU HAVE TO MOVE OVER.
>> I KNOW.
THIS IS A CHAT MADE PARLAY AM
TRYING TO SEE IF THEY CAN GIVE
US SOMETHING AND YOU DON'T PUSH
IT.
>> RYAN IS TRYING TO PUSH HIS
PROPAGANDA THAT HE GAVE TO ME
BEFORE THE SHOW WITH TREVOR
LAWRENCE RUSHING YARDS WE ARE
MOVING ON
>> WHERE'S THE TRUST?
>> WE ASKED THE CHAT THUMBS UP.
>> THE CHAT THE PROBLEM IS FOR
EVERY THREE THUMBS UP THERE IS
ONE, THAT GIVES ME 12 THUMBS
DOWN.
RYAN SAID LET IT GO.
ZACH RUSHING GREATER THAN
LAWRENCE RUSHING DO WE JUST
WANT TO GO WITH 11+ FOR ZACH?
>> KNOW.
I DON'T WANT TO BET ON A
QUARTERBACK .
>> THAT IS FAIR.
>> WE NEED TO BE IN A UNIVERSAL
AGREEMENT UNDER 224.5 YARDS
-310.
>> LET'S LOCK IT IN RYAN.
WE HAVE ZACH LAWSON UNDER 224.5
. I LIKE THAT.
THAT'S SOMETHING AND FEELING
GOOD ABOUT ITS COLD.
ZACH WILSON.
WE HAVE THE ODDS ON OUR SIDE.
I LIKE THIS. SORRY RYAN.
WE ARE TRYING TO WIN.
>> YEAH.
WHATEVER.
YOU GUYS CHOSE TODAY TO FIGHT
ME ON PARLAY SUNDAY IT WAS LIKE
RYAN COOK AND NOW --
>> AND WE LOST!
WE LOST WHEN WE LET YOU COOK.
>> I KNOW.
A LOT OF THUMBS UP ON THE ZACH
WILSON PICK THAT'S A UNIVERSAL
AGREEMENT.
>> THERE IT IS GOOD JOB.
>> ANYTHING THAT STOOD OUT TO
YOU IN YOUR MIND?
WE JUST TOUCHED IT.
I LIKE ZACH WILSON GOING UNDER
I SAW 194 I BELIEVE THAT WE ARE
UP TO 224.5 I LOVE THIS ONE LET
ME GET BACK INTO THE COMMENTS.
THIS ISN'T OUR PLAY THIS IS AN
ABOUT ME THIS ISN'T ABOUT YOU
THIS IS AN ABOUT THEM IT'S
ABOUT THE PEOPLE. TRAVIS J
ALLEN 52 UNDER 65.5.
LET'S JUST ASK THE PEOPLE.
LET'S ASK THEM SEE IF THEY ARE
FEELING IT.
>> HE SAID UNDER 65.5 -- THAT'S
+140.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE HE HAS BEEN.
>> IT'S PLUS MONEY?
>> YES. IT'S +140.
>> RYAN YOU'RE NOT TRYING TO
GET RICH?
>> WHAT ABOUT THE WEATHER
REPORT FOR YOU NOT
UNDERSTANDING?
IT'S RUNNING FOOTBALL WEATHER
GREG.'S
YEAH BUT IT'S LIKE IS HE REALLY
GOING TO GET 65 YARDS?
HERE'S THE CHAT WITH THUMBS
DOWN.
SORRY IF YOU'RE A GIANTS FAN
THREE THUMBS DOWN.
IT'S A NO RIGHT NOW.
>> I MIGHT GO THE OTHER WAY AND
SAY TRAVIS AT 55+ -310.
I'M THROWING THAT OUT THERE.
>> 55+?
>> I LIKE HIM TO SCORE.
HIM SCORING WOULD BE OUR PLUS
MONEY GET RICH.
>> JUST LIKE THAT
>> +155.
YES.
SCORING FOR SURE.
>> I LIKE THAT.
IF THEY WERE FIGHTING THE
COWBOYS AGAIN I WOULD TRY 50
YARDS RUSHING.
I DIDN'T WANT HIM ANYWAY.
THE GIANTS FANS ARE COPING.
>> WILSON.
ALRIGHT.
I'M OKAY WITH DOING THAT OVER
YOU SAID.
>> THEN THE PSYCHE -310 WITH
THE PARLAY.
>> NOTHING THERE IS A FAN
PICTURE OF HIM.
I DON'T HAVE TO TAKE BLAME FOR
IT IF HE LOSES.
>> HE PRACTICED FOR THE FIRST
TIME YESTERDAY VINCE THE INJURY
I DID FORGET HE WAS
QUESTIONABLE FOR THIS.
>> YES.
>> I DO THINK HE WILL PLAY WITH
THIS GAME.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU GUYS SAW
THAT.
>> LET'S ASK THE PEOPLE ABOUT
SAM.
LET'S ASK HIM ABOUT SAM'S PICK
IF YOU LIKE THAT AM SORRY BUT I
REALLY LIKE IT.
>> WE ARE TRYING TO WIN HERE.
>> IT'S TRAVIS OVER 54 RUSHING.
>> -130 WE ARE IN PLUS
TERRITORY WE JUST NEED A PLUS
MONEY PLACE SO THAT WILL BE MY
REQUEST FOR THE CHAT GIVE US A
PLUS MONEY PLAY.
WE HAVE THUMBS UP.
>> YES.
IT COULD BE A TOUCHDOWN SCORE
AGAIN I LIKE THAT BUT THERE ARE
THE INJURY CONCERNS SO WHAT
ABOUT MICHAEL CARTER?
TRAVIS WE CAN JUST DOUBLE UP.
>> I DON'T LIKE DOUBLING UP.
THOSE ARE THE RULES?
WHAT IF WE THREW WIN TOTAL
SACKS 5+ -450 ZACH WILSON ON
THE GROUND TREVOR LAWRENCE IN
THE MIX?
>> I DON'T DISLIKE IT.
RYAN DOESN'T LIKE IT THOUGH.
>> HE SAYS ANY TIME -- WHAT IF
WE DID EVAN INGRAM.
MICHAEL CARTER AT +310.
>> A LOT OF COMMENTARY FROM THE
CHAT ABOUT THE FACT THAT I'M IN
THE KITCHEN AND I HAVE A
DIFFERENT SET UP TODAY.
SHOULD WE CALL YOU CHEF?
>> YES.
EVAN INGRAM 5+ RECEPTIONS?
>> I LIKE THAT.
THAT'S A GOOD TAKE FROM THE
CHAT YOU'RE A BIG TIGHT END I
TOO.
>> LIKE I SAID WE NEED A
CONNECTION TO THE TIGHT END SO
I CAN ATTACK WE WILL DO A
MINISERIES 5+120 LIKE THAT.
IT GETS US TO +320 WITH TWO
LEGS IN THERE THAT SHOULD BE IN
THERE.
>> THAT'S NOT BAD.
>> BEFORE WE DO THIS AFTER SEE
WHAT HE'S BEEN DOING.
I KNOW HE HAS BEEN SCORING BUT
HAS HE BEEN RECEIVING THE BALL
AS OF LATE?
>> MICHAEL IS IN THE CHAT
SAYING THIS IS A FIVE LIKE
PARLAYS SO MAYBE WE DO INGRAM
-475 AND FOR TWO MORE.
>> I GET WHAT YOU SAID WE ARE
TRYING TO WIN RIGHT?
IT'S BEEN TOO LONG.
WHAT IF WE DID FOUR?
>> I LIKE INGRAM AT 4+.
IN HIS LAST THREE GAMES EIGHT
RECEPTIONS 11 RECEPTIONS FIVE
RECEPTIONS.
>> NOW WITH JOE ANOTHER LOCK IN
THERE AND WE ARE AT PLUS NOW
WITH JOE ANOTHER LOCK IN THERE
AND WE ARE AT +250.
>> I LIKE IT AT -1200 THAT'S
PRETTY TWO SEED IN ME.
>> THAT'S FAIR.
AND GETTING YELLED AT TO FOLLOW
THE PLAN.
OKAY.
WE ARE AT THREE WE NEED TWO
MORE.
WE NEED TWO MORE ARM GOING TO
GET YELLED AT.
>> WHERE DO YOU SEE THAT?
>> IN THE DEFENSE PROP SECTION.
>> SAM IS COMING UP WITH
SCOOPS.
>> I WANT TO KNOW WHAT SAM HAS
IN HIS VISION RIGHT NOW WHERE
HIS HEAD KEEPS GOING OFF OF WE
CAN SEE HIM.
>> HAVE MY HANDY DANDY iPAD
GREG IS NOT THE ONLY ONE
LOOKING INTO IT.
I GOT THE CHAT ON MY PHONE I
GOT A LOT OF THINGS WORKINGMAN.
>> SHOULD WE GO THREE?
>> LET'S SEE WHAT TWO DOES.
YOU'RE MAKING THIS TOO WHISKEY.
>> WE CAN DO FOUR LEGS
>> DARREN 85 SAID WE NEED IN
ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN FROM ONE OF
THE RIGHTFAX SO
>> HE'S PROBABLY SAFER BECAUSE
HIS HEALTH -- COME DOWN TO DO
CARTER.
>> MICHAEL CARTER MAKES THIS.
THIS IS MY TERRITORY NOW
>> SHOULD WE ASK THE CHAT
CARTER?
>> YES.
THAT'S IT.
>> I ALSO LIKE GARRETT WILSON
TOO.
>> YES?
>> I LIKE HIM.
I THINK HE WILL SCORE TODAY.
>> I DON'T HATE THAT AT ALL.
AND SCARED WILSON ON YOUR TEAM?
>> UNFORTUNATELY HE'S NOT.
>> I WANTED TO KNOW IF THAT IS
A BIASED TAKE.
>> HE IS NOT ON MY FANTASY
TEAM.
THE OTHER FOUR SHOULD BE LOCKED
WITH GARRETT WILSON IN THE END
ZONE.
>> EXACTLY WE ARE WINNING.
>> DO WE WANT TO GO HIGHER ON
THE PASSING YARDS?
>> DOING UNDER 250 AND -600?
>> I'M SURPRISED YOU GUYS ARE
DRESSING THAT.
GREG AND I ARE ON THE SIDE OF
DON'T GET YELLED AT BY THE FANS
BECAUSE THEN YOU'RE ON THE SIDE
OF WINNING THE MOST GAMES AND
TAKING THE BIGGEST RISKS YOU'RE
NOT IN THE COMMENTS.
>> LOVE YOU.
>> THAT'S GREAT.
>> YOU ACT LIKE THERE'S NOT A
REASON FOR THAT IF YOUR 5 ON 1
THE CHAT IS WEALTHY BECAUSE OF
ME IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
I FEEL LIKE AND I -- I FEEL
LIKE A FINANCIAL ADVISER.
>> HE MADE IT HIMSELF.
>> IT'S BEEN SIX WEEKS MAN.
>> UNBELIEVABLE.
>> THE FUNNIEST THING RYAN
DROPPED HIS RECORD ON TWITTER I
WAS GOING TO TWEAK YOU IS THE
S.A.F.E.
ACT?
IS THIS JUST LIKE RYAN?
IS THIS A RYAN FACT?
>> A RYAN FACT IS SOMETHING
THAT HAS TO BE VERIFIED IT HAS
TO BE CONFIRMED.
IN FACT IS A FACT.
>> THAT'S PRETTY GOOD.
7-1. RYAN FLYING TOO CLOSE TO
THE SON.
>> AGREED.
>> I THINK EVERYTHING ELSE
THOUGH NO WALKER I DON'T KNOW I
CAN SEE ZACH WILSON HOLDING
ONTO THE BALL FOR TOO LONG.
THAT'S NOT HAPPENING.
THE ONLY THING WE WOULD HAVE TO
SWEAT IS THE GARRETT WILSON
TOUCHDOWN.
>> DARIEN 85 SAID I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THE WILSON TOUCHDOWN I
LIKE IT.
I FEEL GOOD ABOUT IT BUT SHOULD
WE ASK THE CHAT SHOULD WE JUST
CONFIRM WITH THE CHAT?
>> I FEEL AT THIS POINT THAT IS
GOING TO BE THE CONTROVERSIAL
LEG PRESSURE.
IF YOU'RE DISAGREEING WITH ANY
OF THE OTHER PLAYS THAT SONG
YOU.
>> THE CHAT IS GOING TO SAY
CARTER OR WILSON.
THOSE FOUR NAMES THOSE FOUR
NAMES AT THE TOP.
NIGHT, CARTER, WILSON YOU GUYS
LET US KNOW WHAT YOU DO ON THIS
PARLAY AND WE WILL DO IT.
>> IF YOU DIDN'T GIVE THE
DOUBLE UP I WOULD HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO BE TALKED INTO THAT.
>> THAT'S TOO WHISKEY.
I DON'T WANT TO TOUCH KIRK OR
JONES IT'S LINED UP AGAINST
EITHER OF THOSE GUYS.
THAT GUY IS JUST INSANE.
HE MIGHT BE THE BEST
QUARTERBACK IN THE SPORT.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO LIFE.
INGRAM?
I HAVE MY LITTLE TIGHT END ARMY
IN HERE.
>> I SEE THEM.
>> I'M TIRED OF SWEATING LEGS
WE SAID LOCKS ONLY.
I TIRED OF SWEATING LEGS TOO
I'M TIRED OF LOSING THESE
PARLAYS.
THE CHAT IS DIVIDED THERE IS A
LOT OF LOVE AND THEN IT SEEMS
LIKE THERE IS A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO DON'T EVEN WANT ANYTHING
WITH THIS PARLAY ROUND.
THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
LIVE.
>>
>> THE CASH THOUGH.
>> THAT'S A GOOD POINT I CAN'T
ARGUE THAT.
>> THERE'S A LOT OF INGRAM LOVE.
IT'S TOO WHISKEY.
>> WE SEE CONKLIN ANYTIME?
THAT'S A GOOD NOTE.
IT DOESN'T EVEN DO THAT MUCH.
TYLER I SAW.
ELIJAH MORRIS WILL NOT GET A
RECEPTION.
>> I MORE COMFORTABLE DOUBLING
UP BECAUSE I WANT A WINNER.
THESE GUYS ARE GURUS.
YOU GUYS TOOK INGRAM YOU SHOULD
HAVE GONE SAFER.
>> WE LIVE A DIFFERENT LIFE
THEY CALLED ME A GURU.
WHAT'S YOUR RECORD I GUESS.
>> IT'S GOOD.
>> YOU'RE NOT AND I TOLD YOU SO
GUY.
MICHAEL CARTER ANY TIME WITH
THE TOUCHDOWN
>> I'LL TELL YOU THIS.
IF WE TOOK THIS PARLAY AND
TWEETED OUT THE COMMENTS WILL
BE LIKE THAT'S KIND OF NICE.
>> THESE ARE THE COMMENTS THAT
MATTER.
SHOULD WE LOCK THIS ONE IN AND
PUT OUR FOOT DOWN?
SHOULD WE PUT OUR FOOT DOWN
SAM?
>> THIS IS IT.
NOT DONOVAN?
>> HE'S HURT.
>> WE ARE LOCKING THIS AND WE
ARE PUTTING THE FOOT DOWN READ
IT OFF FOR THE PEOPLE.
OKAY.
>> OVER 54 1/2 CRUSHING YARDS
FOR TRAVIS 3+ RECEPTIONS
PRIVATE INGRAM.
2+ SACKS FOR THE JACKSONVILLE
JAGUARS UNDER 249 1/2 PASSING
YARDS FOR ZACH WILSON.
ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN TRAVIS.
>> MY TICKETS MIGHT NOT WE WILL
SEE.
FIVE LEGS FOR +100 ODDS.
>> THERE IT IS.
>> AND THERE'S ANOTHER BOOST SO
THAT CAN HELP US OUT A LITTLE
BIT.
>> THERE IT IS.
THERE IT IS.
>> DID WE LOSE HIM?
ALRIGHT.
WHILE -- I FEEL LIKE THIS IS A
BETTER TIME THAN EVER TO GET IN
ON THE JIK PROPAGANDA.
>> THAT IS THE PARLAY.
>> COME BACK GUYS I DON'T KNOW
WHAT HAPPENED.
I'M RIGHT HERE THAT'S THE
PARLAY.
MAKE SURE YOU GUYS TELL US
UNLOCK THIS PARLAY IN.
ARE YOU GUYS READY FOR OUR BEST
BETS?
THAT'S WHAT TIME IT IS IT'S
TIME FOR OUR BETS . I WILL HAVE
SAM GO FIRST AND THEN MR.5-1
NEXT TO THAT HE WILL GO SECOND.
AND THEN I'M GOING AROUND AND
THEN I WILL GO THIRD AND WE
WILL GET INTO OUR NEXT SEGMENT
SO THIS IS OUR BEST BETS.
SAM YOU DON'T HAVE 45 SECONDS
BUT TAKE IT AWAY BROTHER WHO
ARE YOU ROCKING WITH TODAY?
>> I'M TAKING THE JIK MONEY
LINE TONIGHT  IT SUCKS THAT WE
DON'T HAVE ZACH WILSON.
IT'S JUST TOO GOOD OF A SPOT.
THEY ARE A LITTLE BIT OUT OF
CONTROL.
I DO NEED TO GET A CHEFS HAT
THIS IS JUST BUYING LOW ON THE
JIK AFTER A ROUGH COUPLE WEEKS
SELLING HIGH AFTER SOME MONSTER
WINS.
TO MEET SHOULD BE CLOSER TO
THREE AND THEY DIDN'T END UP
GETTING THERE.
WE WILL BE AROUND THE GROUND
THE JIK DEFENSE WILL BE ON THE
FIELD SOONER.
I DON'T THINK THEY ASKED TOO
MUCH COMING AROUND THEY'RE
GOING TO LOOK ALIVE WITH
DONOVAN.
>> SAM IS ROCKING WITH THE JIK
ALL RIGHT.
RYAN?
>> JUST REALLY QUICK HE PUT
NOT CASHING.
I APPRECIATE THE APOLOGY.
IT'S THE MONEY LINE ALL DAY.
I DON'T KNOW WHY WE DON'T HAVE
MY RECORD AT THE BOTTOM.
THAT'S OKAY.
WHAT'S THE NEXT BIG THING?
HE'S NOT PART OF THE REASON HE
FEELS THE WAY I DO.
THEY WILL RUN THE BALL.
THEY WILL WIN THE GAME.
THEY REALLY REALLY NEED TO WIN.
THEY ARE A DESPERATE AND HUNGRY
CHATS TEAM.
THEY ARE IN THE SAME BOAT AS
YOU SAM SO CONGRATS.
>> FINAL ONE.
I GUESS IT'S MY TURN.
THE WAY THEY BATTLED THAT LAST
WEEK THERE FIGHTING.
WE ALL KNOW WHO THEIR
QUARTERBACK IS.
WE ALL KNOW HIS STRUGGLES.
WE ALL KNOW WHO ZACH WILSON IS
ANYTHING THE JAGUARS CAN REVERSE
THAT.
THEY ARE 0-4 IN COLD WEATHER.
THEY WERE 0-4 WITH COLD WEATHER.
I KNOW THE WEATHER WILL BE BAD
BUT THEY WILL REVERSE IT TODAY
YOU TWO ARE ON THE JIK AM ON
THE OTHER SIDE . I'M ON THE
SEASON YEAR.
THROWING A LITTLE SALT IN THE
CHAT IN THE ROOM.
>> ARE YOU NOT WORRIED ABOUT
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS GAME AND
YOU LOOK AT THE ELEMENTS THAT
WILL TAKE AWAY THE BIGGEST EDGES
THEY HAVE IN THIS GAME?
SWITCHES THEY HAVE A REALLY
STRONG PASSER AND TACKLING
AGAINST ZACH WILSON WHO
LITERALLY MIGHT BE THE WORST
QUARTERBACK I'VE EVER SEEN IN
MY LIFE?
BUT YOU TAKE AWAY THOSE EDGES
WITH THE WEATHER AND THEN THE
GAME IS PLAYED ON THE GROUND.
>> YOU HAVE A GREAT POINT BUT
YOU JUST MENTIONED THE REASON
I'M ROCKING WITH THE JIK  THE
QUARTERBACK FOR THE CHATS THE
JAGUARS DEFENSE HAS BEEN DECENT
THEY CAN GET TO THE QUARTERBACK.
THEY CAN STOP THE RUN THEY HAVE
SOME LINEBACKERS THERE THEY
WILL RUN IT UP A LITTLE BIT WE
ARE GOING TO SEE THE GAME.
>> WE CAN TALK TERMS.
JUST MAKE SURE WE GET DOUBLE OR
NOTHING ON THE NEXT SHOW.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
WHAT ARE THE PEOPLE TALKING
ABOUT?
>> RILEY SAYS -- THE GIANTS WAS
MAYBE WORSE.
IT'S JUST ONE.
HE SAYS 2010 CHATS.
I THINK THAT'S THE SCORE YOU
ARE PREDICTING.
JOSHUA SAYS HE'S GOING TO FAIL
TONIGHT. I GUESS WE HAVE ANOTHER
QUESTION YEAR.
I BELIEVE DRAFTKINGS IS
BOOSTING 50% PROFIT ON WHAT
OTHER SIDE YOU CHOOSE.
DO YOU GUYS THINK THERE WILL BE
AN OFFENSE SCORE?
>> I WILL TAKE A NO RIGHT THERE.
EVERYTHING ABOUT THIS GAME IS
LOW-SCORING.
THE JIK HAVE A REALLY GOOD
DEFENSE AND IT REALLY BAD
QUARTERBACK WHOEVER'S ON THE
FIELD  IS GOING TO STRUGGLE TO
SCORE AND YES YOU HAVE
DIFFERENT CONDITIONS I WILL SAY
THERE IS A SMART COMMENT IN THE
CHAT ABOUT HOW MUCH MORE THE
WIN MATTERS THAN THE ACTUAL
TEMPERATURE IT'S GOING TO BE
VERY WINDY TONIGHT. WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THESE GAMES THIS
WEEKEND NOT TO DERAIL THE
CONVERSATION IT'S GOING TO BE
COLD EVERYWHERE BUT LOOK AT THE
WIND.
CAN BE COLD IT CAN BE SNOW IF
IT'S NOT WINDY THERE WILL BE
POINTS IF IT'S WINDY THE SCORE
GOES DOWN.
>> I LIVE 15 MINUTES FROM THE
STADIUM I STEPPED OUTSIDE THIS
MORNING AND MOVED AROUND AND
THE WIND WAS TOO MUCH.
I'M GOING TO SAY THEY WILL SCORE
WITH THE OFFENSE.
>> I'M ROCKING WITH THE
QUARTERBACK WITH ELEMENTS,
WIND, WEATHER.
WHATEVER SIDE YOU GUYS ARE
UNREMEMBERED TO GET ON
DRAFTKINGS AND TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THAT PROFIT BOOST THEY GOT
YOU SEE IT ON THE SCREEN.
IT'S TIME TO GRADE IT'S TIME TO
DROP YOUR PICKS IN THE CHAT AND
WE WILL GRADE THEM.
GARRETT WILSON ANY TIME.
ALSO I JUST WANT TO ADDRESS THE
COMMENT IN THE CHAT THAT SAID
WHENEVER SOMETHING IS BOOSTED
GO THE OPPOSITE.
YOU CAN BET ANY SIDE YOU WANT .
YOU LITERALLY GET TO BET WHAT
YOU WANT GET OUT OF HERE WITH
THE BOOST . MAKE YOUR PICK
WHATEVER SIDE YOU WANT AND GET
AN EXTRA BOOST ON IT.
>> SAM IT'S THE HOLIDAY SEASON.
THE HOSTILITY YOU JUMPED IN
WITH.
>> IT'S JUST LIKE -- THEY ARE
BEING NEGATIVE IN CHAT. WERE
TRYING TO DO LIVE.
>> I FEEL YOU SAM.
>> HERE'S A TAKE. PUNTER SMALL
SAYS  ZACH WILSON IS GREATER
THAN ANY QUARTERBACK IN THE AFC
EAST.
>> HE MIGHT BE THE BEST
QUARTERBACK I'VE SEEN IN THE
LEAGUE.
>> IT'S SO SCARY TO BET ON THAT
GUY.
HE'S IN THE TOP 10.
DARIEN 85 HE DROPPED IT IN
COMMUNITY EARLIER.
NO TEAM TO SCORE THREE
UNANSWERED CALLS.
>> THAT'S FROM OUR GOOD FRIEND.
YES.
WHAT IS IT?
>> IT'S +145 SO NO TEAM SCORED.
YOU THROWING A BUNCH OF BIG
WORDS OUT THERE I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THEY MEAN.
HOPEFULLY THE CHAT GETS THAT.
THERE SOME MONEY THAT YOU MADE.
TREVOR LAWRENCE OVER .200.
>> I WOULD TAKE BOTH THE
QUARTERBACK I REALLY DO.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE JONES.
JUST BECAUSE HE'S USUALLY ON
THE OUTSIDE.
NOTHING ELSE.
>> PEOPLE IN THE CHAT GOT ME.
THAT'S LIKE THE FUNNIEST THING
ONLINE.
MOSTLY 11+ TACKLES.
THESE ARE WEIRD ONES.
>> YEAH THAT IS WEIRD I LIKE
THE WAY HE ROAMS AROUND THE
FIELD WHEREVER THE BALL IS YOU
SEE HIM IN THERE.
WHAT WAS IT?
13?
11?
>> I LIKE IT IF THEY ARE GOING
TO RUN THE BALL -- A LOT OF
TACKLES.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
I DO WANT TO GIVE ONE MORE.
I'M STAYING AWAY BECAUSE IT'S
SORT OF A GUESSING GAME.
I WOULD JUST BE VERY CAREFUL
THERE.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A LOT OF
DEFENSE RIGHT THERE.
THEY JUST MIGHT TAKE IT.
>> I AM A MAN OF THE PEOPLE I
WANT TO SEE IF THEY HAVE A
QUESTION.
>> THAT'S OUR SHOW THINK YOU
EVERYONE FOR WATCHING.
I WOULD LEAN OVER BUT IT WAS
-160.
WE WANT -500.
>> DON'T LET THE ODDS TELL YOU
WHAT THAT IS.
>> WE NEED THAT ON A SHIRT.
>> REMEMBER THAT RYAN.
LITERALLY REMEMBER THAT QUOTE
OKAY?
BRING IT BACK UP.
I CLIP OUT EVERYTHING I SAY ON
THE SHELF.
JUST IN CASE.
>> CLIP THAT OUT AND THEN MAKE
BRYSON RETWEET THAT THAT'S A
FUNNY SHIRT.
>> THERE IT IS.
THERE IS SOME MONEY TO BE MADE
TONIGHT.
MY NAME IS GREG IVORY.
NEXT TO ME SAM RICHMOND NEXT TO
HIM IS RYAN THE PRODUCER RYAN
THAT'S WHAT WE CALL HIM. RYAN I
THINK THEY WANT YOU TO GO OVER
THE PARLAY ONE MORE TIME.
>> IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
ZACH WILSON UNDER 249.5 PASSING
YARDS TRAVIS OVER 54 1/2
RUSHING YARDS EVAN INGRAM 3+
RECEPTIONS JACKSONVILLE JAGUARS
2+ AND TRAVIS ANYTIME TOUCHDOWN
THAT'S FIVE THAT ADD UP TO +400
ODDS WE KNOW IT'S CHALKY BUT
IT'S A LOT.
>> THERE IT IS IT DOESN'T
MATTER IF IT'S CHALKY.
>> I'M ON THE OTHER SIDE.